roselyne juste un petit message
personnel avant qu'on commence
noël mamère oui ils vous adore oui c'est
quand oui c'est quand vous voulez là
vous avez oui j'ai un ticket d'en faire
exister bien vous êtes la femme la plus
séduisante dès qu'on demande à un homme
politique qu'elle est la femme la plus
séduisante pour vous c'est toujours
roselyne bachelot pour noël mamère je
partage avec elisabeth guigou ouais donc
je sais que quand même un homme debout
ce type on a beau dire jean saint-josse
les mobs enfin peut pas plaire à tout le
monde non comment tu t'habilles qui
filme appelle d'abord tu t'habilles
après
déjà fait et à qui on l'a proposé un
tube est d'abord tu t'habilles après les
couleurs c'est aux gens étonnants à
toujours vouloir de rejoindre les
premières gardelli tout en noir avec une
touche tout allait parfaitement bien
alain soral bonsoir donc d'abord j'ai
présenté un petit peu alain soral
ensuite bonjour vous présente plus mais
je rappellerai quand même de trois
points sur les sur les chiennes de garde
donc alain soral vous et vous est sorti
un bouquin qui s'appelle vers la
féminisation aux éditions blanche que je
dois avoir là et que je montre à la
caméra comme on fait la télé voilà vers
la féminisation alain soral vous êtes
l'auteur avoue est un des trois co
auteur des mouvements de mode expliquer
aux parents qui est sorti en 84 avec
hector obalk et alexandre pasche en 96
les sorties sociologie du dragueur et
aujourd'hui donc vers la féminisation
alors vous quand on vous dit la femme
est l'avenir de l'homme ça résume un peu
pour vous le credo actuelle le credo de
l'époque l'idéologie de l'époque et
alors vous dites en parents au sujet de
cette phrase laurent écoute
sa tâche
il va vers la féminisation
et il est chaud là
j'avais mis les hommes d'un côté les
femmes on va parler des hommes et des
femmes n'est pas l'émission après on se
lève on se caresse les seins
et goldwater
justement je me réjouis
bien alors j'en reviens alain soral la
femme est l'avenir de l'homme alors ça
résume pour vous un petit peu le credo
de l'époque à l'idéologie de l'époque et
vous dites sujet de cette phrase que le
poète qu'il l'a prononcée est vécue en
stalinien et finit en [ __ ] ça devrait
pourtant inciter à la prudence en
parlant d'aragon et à la réflexion et à
la réflexion tout le monde tout le monde
aura du monde
alors vous vous pensez que la
féminisation coupe court à toute
réflexion sérieuse parce qu'en fait les
femmes cette idée c'est une idée qui est
lancée par par l'oligarchie parce qu'on
dit fond sur faut monter les femmes il
faut valoriser sa soeur contre les far
bien sûr
je vais essayer de m'en sortir deux
trois sérieuses ouais déjà moi je fais
une remarque parce qu'il faudrait
surtout pas poser le débat genre sommes
opposés aux femmes respect à mark ségard
10,1 à poser l'origine d'avoir l'origine
de ces le couple il faut que les hommes
et les femmes soient ensemble pour qui
l'humanité soit wayne déjà c'est de
cette distinction est très abstraite 1
et deuxièmement la femme n'est pas une
catégorie sociale yara ya pas du comment
dirais-je de connivence politique et
d'intérêts communs entre une rentière
une ouvrière et une cadre du tertiaire
par exemple donc quand on parle de
condition masculine moi je dis mais de
quel homme par le ton puisque finalement
la couture masculine ça ne veut rien
dire ça dépend de la position sociale à
condition féminine c'est nul et non
avenu qu'à la condition masculine rien
dire oui ça au jugement par être
d'accord j'essaye d'expliquer ce qui
veut dire ont donc l'appareil n'est pas
là pour être d'accord la barre et des
plans pensez quoi c'est très dangereux
parce que à gauche moi pour les non
parce que c'est à dire qu'une femme qui
est compétente revendiquent le pouvoir
au nom de sa compétence et une femme
incompétente revendiquent le pouvoir au
nom de sa féminité jamais complètement
comme les hommes quoi on veut trouver
normal que les femmes à qualification
professionnelle et gagnent gagnent moins
que les hommes c'est ça c'est un chiffre
qu'il faut bien nuancé parce que c'est
pas grave pour la rente c'est pas vrai
pour les professions libérales c'est pas
vrai pour le commerce c'est pas vrai
pour les droits d'auteur ce n'est vrai
que pour les salariés et encore et on
peut savoir si en plus il ya de plus ou
moins qu une shampouineuse
interchangeables est ce qu'on peut
savoir si une mason est moins payé qu'un
maçon ce ne sont pas des métiers
interchangeables donc je dis que souvent
les réponses viennent du fait des
question mal posée ceci dit c'est vrai
qu'il ya un léger différentiel de
salaire en danger les femmes gagnent
qu'il faut compenser puisqu'il à travail
égal salaire égal mais simplement c'est
une raison historique c'est que je dis
la famille de femmes au boulot parce
qu'on les payer moins et quand une femme
est une entreprise à la même logique
celle de faire du profit on va se dire
c'est que la loi du capital et l'unisexe
1 elle a fait pas de sentiment et
certains comme les immigrés quoi vous
exactement bien sûr on comprend les eaux
paisibles et moins cher et on paye les
femmes moins cher dans certains médias
madame bachelot les mieux payés que moi
donc c'est aussi une question de
position sociale voyez
pas ce qu'on veut dire en gros ça veut
dire en gros pour résumer la situation
vous avez une vision politique des
choses en disant ce qui compte c'est les
riches et les pauvres s'est blessé parce
que quand on veut résumer votre position
à la réfugiée regarder les chiffres il
n'y a que quatorze députés qui sont
originaires du monde ouvrier et c'est
sans doute pour ça que l'intérêt des
pauvres si mal défendu en france
commençons par la parité riches pauvres
ça sera la première à faire alors que la
parité hommes femmes ça va être les
femmes et les filles de la bourgeoisie
dominante qui vont partager le gâteau
n'est ce pas parce que quand on regarde
les cv chaque fois que j'ai eu des
débats d'ailleurs ça tombait pile sept
jours des femmes et des filles de la
bourgeoisie de gauche ou de droite c'est
la bourgeoisie montante où la
bourgeoisie déjà en place qui simplement
prend la place du père ou du frère ou du
mari je dirais donc moi je veux ce que
j'aimerais bien c'est que ça amène des
ouvrières comme députés mais son ami ne
rate pas sa marque et les professions
libérales alors j'ai lu votre livre si
ce n'est pas toujours qui est beaucoup
moins clair que ce que vous dites là je
veux dire parce que là je dis votre
livre est moins clair que ce que vous
racontez là c'est lumineux les comme une
coquille est ce que c'est un livre de
pauvres c'est un livre de pauvres page
65 de correcteurs page 65 vous dit il
n'y a guère que les gays pour croire que
leur appartenance sexuelle puisse tenir
lieu de condition sociale bien ça c'est
vrai
l'acquéreur du gafi se faire [ __ ]
c'est une activité propre productive son
activité de loisir donc entre le entre
l'enculé dentiste et l'enculé routier et
l'enculé rentiers ils se rencontrent
dans la pissotière mais c'est toujours
le même conclu l'hôte sur la feuille de
paye cash et je répète la phrase il n'y
a guère que les gués pour croire que
leur appartement sexuelles puissent
tenir lieu de condition sociale est il
écrit je trouve ça formidable et austère
lapsus génial il n'y a guère j'ai eu à
eux j'ai hagler le rer e à la mini
guerre voilà
c'est pas mal en même temps c'est pas
les moyens de se payer beaucoup de
centenaires du futur mécanisme à deux
balles c'est une
peu de rapports de classe est ce que
stéphane je vous prends comme cobaye est
ce que c'est clair la position de soral
c'est clair ce qui dit alors je suis pas
un être consensuel pourtant mais il ya
des choses justes dans ce qu'ils y
attendais pas non il ya des choses
vraiment juste c'est historique est
juste la presse est ce que je n'aime pas
dans les quotas c'est qu'on va dire il
ya le quota de noir c'est comme aux
états unis où le quota de femmes le
quota de noir le quota de juifs
d'ailleurs on s'énerve parce que quand
on commence à dire qu'il y'a pas assez
noir d'autres gens avec le même principe
vont peut-être faire romaric ya trop de
juifs c'est très dangereux ça nous
ramène à pétain c'est exactement ça
d'ailleurs on faisait faire des listes
de quotas on voulait faire des quotas
comme ça on disait combien pétain appelé
hitler vous en voulez combien cette fois
ci ouais 5000 bas on vous les envoie à
ses artistes et à lister un monarchiste
rini
coudes on disait la monarchie c'est
l'anarchie plus un c'est vrai donc voilà
position d'alain soral fois on sait
pourtant mais ce qu'il dit et non mais
ce qu'il dit c'est un fait ça c'est net
d'accord avec lui aux usa se dira pas du
tout d'accord avec nous les seuls les
communistes nous ont fait ce refrain là
depuis le début tiens classe c'est à
dire que le féminisme empêche le combat
de classe alors si je vais présenter
votre votre je vous ai pas à présenter
aux lits mais bon donc vous sortez pacs
entre nos montres pauline de soral dans
le live
vous sortez pas axe entre haine et amour
voilà un chez plon alors vous êtes
contente c'est voter maintenant faire
quoi mais le combat il ne fait quand
même que de commencer sur un certain
nombre de choses que je décris dans le
bouquin en particulier l'homophobie ce
que quand même si je reprends le livre
d'alain soral et quand on lit les gays
n'étant jamais que l'ensemble des effets
mines et du tertiaire dont la conscience
politique se limite au droit de se faire
[ __ ] bon bah j'ai trouvé que celle
encore tout à fait cette phrase c'est
vrai chez les gays des accords
d'amsterdam ne veut rien dire puisque
les gays c'est pas une catégorie sociale
ça dépend de leurs intérêts de classe
entre le guet ouvriers et le guerre
entier il ya aucun intérêt commun c'est
un mensonge et ces catégories poli dans
une société de logistique de son nom
dans une société comme la société
française où véritablement l'homophobie
reste encore quelque chose vraiment
elles sont habillées
terre te faire louer des appartements la
couple de gays du tertiaire à fort
pouvoir d'achat car un couple des
terreaux qui serait dans des secteurs
fortement touchée par le chômage tout ça
c'était que ses démons sont ils
attendaient ce que tu n'es pas c'est
quand et pdt ouvriers que tu habites la
province et que tu es dans un coin paumé
tout ça c'est parce que tu es marginale
parce que tu es seul bien sur
les côtés sdf tacle vie sexuelle non
plus monsieur sera le chant vous aurez
vivait sans doute dans un milieu
privilégié
pas trop moche anthony d'actes orphelins
là vous avez raté
vous rêviez dans un milieu privilégié où
on est tolérant que c'est pas une
question à vivre dans un milieu
privilégié j'ai pas dis milieu riche ça
n'a rien à voir une grand mère je vous
avais je veux une grand-mère qui
savaient ni lire ni écrire et qui était
une femme merveilleuse dans les rentes
intelligente et d'une certaine façon
cultiver le rectorat elle compte
maintenant 40 il encore encline à la je
vous un coup là mais il ya des gens très
riches et qui sont absolument
intolérants et imbuvable et j'en ai reçu
un certain nombre de lettres dans ce
bouquin cette dame de versailles qui me
dit il faut tuer les homosexuels parce
qu'ils le demandent d'ailleurs pour un
marginal et c'est facile vous rendez pas
compte qu'il dit c'est qu'il ya pas de
ya pas de solidarité en fait qu'il ya
des homosexuels riches des pauvres et
que les vrais fini c'était vrai
appartenance à son compte comme on peu
de justice de solidarité
mais le combat pour l'égalité entre les
hommes et les femmes le combat contre
l'homophobie
c'est un combat qu'il faut il faut mener
tous ses combats l'ensemble
c'est l'impression qu'il ya un combat
qui cachent leurs hôtes et clinker ultra
un petit détail et l'autre est
fondamentale à savoir si avec l'argent
on va construire des hôpitaux ou des
piscines pour certains hommes politiques
c'est un peu ça quand même l'enjeu et sa
de savoir si le mec est homosexuel par
etc il ya la france est un pays de
tolérance notamment là-dessus incroyable
dans tout les mêmes privilégient a
toujours eu beaucoup de guérison tour
est toujours occupée par les
voilà justement dans les milieux
défavorisés site et si en plus tu es en
province ou dans le fin vraiment de nom
mais je connais
c'est ce qui est un homosexuel paysans
c'est sans doute plus douloureux qui est
homosexuel et les bourgeois du tertiaire
ce qui veut bien dire que d'ailleurs ça
va ensemble
l'isie surtout au moment du message mais
qu'est ce que la politique qu'est ce que
la politique au sens sérieux du terrain
peut faire à ça c'est ça le problème
puisque la politique peut il faire rien
soit on en parle parce qu'il n'y a pas
d'enjeu politique derrière donc ça fait
joli c'est de l'animation culturelle
mais comme de toute façon à ce que vous
êtes en train de dire alain soral c'est
que le bouquin de roselyne j'ai des
atouts de cette la lutte contre
l'homophobie tue c'est de l'animation
culturelle pour masquer les vrais
regardez-la historiquement quand qu'on a
fait donc les l'anticléricalisme au
début du siècle quand le clergé n'était
plus un problème politique on a dit les
méchants c'est les curés parce que
c'était réglé parce que pendant ce temps
une nouvelle bourgeoisie qui avait
accédé au pouvoir se remplissent les
poches et voulait pas être montrés du
doigt les nazis ont fait ça avec les
juifs ont dit les méchants c'est les
juifs et aujourd'hui on dit les méchants
c'est les hommes donc donc la
répartition des tâches ménagères et des
habous primé mais quand vous regardez
les hommes et des femmes prisonnières
sont deux giros aussi vous parler des
hommes aux primes il
m'a dit oui
mais
d'abord pour ma condition parce que je
suis une femme et mabrouk est une femme
noire rasta fatwas dont je vais mener
mon propre combat tu vois ça c'est
normal quand même tu peux pas dire tout
mon temps pas être politisée mais
derrière les ouvriers dans une société
dont la patronne est une femme si pour
augmenter son profil te délocalisent
qu'est-ce que ça tarde à apporter
d'avoir été mis au chômage par une femme
tout part un homme vient pas de
solidarité de sexe et c'est ne pas
comprendre la réalité du politique la
lutte et du politique c'est les rapports
économiques donc ce que par contre je
remarque une chance et que les femmes
ont toujours attendre sa sexualisé à
psychologiser le politique et c'est
parce que les hommes au pouvoir s'en
sont rendu compte qu'ils nous vendent de
la féminité en permanence passé comme ça
ils font leurs affaires tranquille c'est
un complot anti democracia exacte de la
stratégie des leurs on a on a vu on a
fait bouffer du curé on a bouffé du juif
aujourd'hui on bouffe de l'homme soit
disant du macho quand j'ai vu ce peu de
monsieur san ce pauvre monsieur saint
josse caméra sur dix à vingt six monty
pays' aux antilles mecque de la campagne
très violent de votre part mme c'était
au soir oui un peu parce que c'était le
mec de la campagne qui passent à la
moulinette par les gens de la ville là
pour moyens vers saint gaudens et
chasseurs et non chasseurs non non
c'était plus par une activité rurale
betteraviers on arrive à ce qu
a pris plein la gueule et là je me dis
pas moins vite se soucie gens pensent
que leur poste le dérégler là
je le mets sais
pas ce que donnera pas suivant la parole
et que les choses importantes à dire est
que les gens quand ils entendent sai
l'impression d'entendre un peu autre
chose que du catéchisme et une connerie
c'est vrai voilà alors c'est pas
forcément de route parce que c'est des
conneries possible enfin beaucoup alors
je crois que je crois qu on devrait
s'entend parce que le fait justement je
veux bien si le dollar est de dire des
choses qui sont soit changée alors
chargé dans la politique le fait de
faire que les femmes prennent leurs
responsabilités c'est aussi une manière
de formidablement déranger les rapports
de pouvoir qui vous chagrine lfc mémé
exactement venir faire d'études
historiques dans mon livre excusez moi
les foils laissez moi parler de minutes
au nom de quoi vous barrent au nom de la
parité 1 1 voilà pas de la galanterie
en plus vous progressez si vous
n'écoutez pas les autres vous n'aimez
pas les êtres humains visiblement cinéma
du psychologisme ados francs et elle se
dresse fait pour l'éditeur vise pas de
secours mais vous n'écoutez que vous
même les yeux j'ai zéro serge bonne idée
ce sujet a indiqué on vous coupe le
micro si vous l'ouvrez à lyon mais on
est dans un monde vous avez décidé qu'il
était pourri on était dans des rapports
économiques complètement vicié tu sais
moi je vous propose une bonne solution
pour sortir de cela fait contrer les
femmes dans la politique vous allez voir
à quel point ça va déranger lanouf avec
l'intérêt de thatcher ils sont morts
mais
le problème c'est de faire rentrer
benazir bhutto est en prison en ce
moment pour le problème ce n'est pas
d'avoir une femme premier ministre ou
d'une femme présidente de la république
le problème c'est de baleiniers 50% des
sommes qui sont actuellement au pouvoir
c'est d'avoir 100 et les femmes du même
milieu social ça changera rien à la on
attendait la question cela justement la
question est posée la fin des belles
catégorie statistique ons mais pas peut
mener les on ne peut pas montrer les
combats de je ne sais pas je ne peux pas
quel rapport entre vous et arlette
laguiller sur le plan de la de la
politique sérieuse yonath écrasé une
vache cloud et élus et pas l'autre si
haut si elle est députée européenne le
travail des six chemins c'est parce que
je lui ai dit attends là voilà ce que je
voulais dire sa gueule non j'aime à bord
dont bon nombre ont tripoté
préférez liste du bac
non je veux dire c'est que vous êtes élu
de la nation dont la république j'ai au
parlement à l'assemblée nationale ce qui
n'est pas le cas de l'art des députés
européens et députés européens certes
mais ce que je veux dire par là c'est
que des bureaux selon m c'est madame la
ministre et la gare et thatcher c'est un
[ __ ] parce qu'elle a serré la main à
pinochet pas une [ __ ] parce que c'est
une injure sexistes et c'est moi j'avais
promis avec les chiennes de garde
justement c'est mort stop à le faire
tout en se montrent donc les chiennes de
garde dans good et on va parler des
chiennes de garde aussi ça a commencé
avec les galeries lafayette quand ya eu
les top models vivante dans les dents là
dans les vitrines on avait parlé
d'ailleurs ici c'est une historienne qui
s'appelle florence montreynaud benoît
labre à césar ce qui est à césar et non
vie formidable petit jeune fille
clémentine voilà que les martyrs que
j'ai eu à clémentine et donc ça l'était
mixité voit la mixité voilà donc ça
c'était le début de l'affairé le 8 mars
99 dominique voynet a été insulté ou ton
slip [ __ ] autant slip [ __ ]
au salon de l'agriculture au salon de
l'agriculture
on aurait dû demander à jean saint-josse
s'il était d'accord il aurait dit non
élu à ses seins je suis allé à lui
s'était dit il très
polyvalent s'élabore donc voix n'est
laissée dans une réunion de chasseurs
vous tout seul un
à la palombe
one est donc alors ya eu les chiennes de
garde qui ont été créés 1 pourquoi
chienne demandé princesse parce que ces
provocateurs
en parler ne peut pas s'appeler les
chattes de garde en même temps ça
faisait
chen
une chaîne de garde on se rend compte
que rice et la femelle du char garder
les nouveaux chiens de garde les plus
efficaces pour verrouiller le pouvoir
tel qu'il est et vendre du faux
progressisme ce sont les chiennes de
garde dire ces fausses féministes qui
décident ou critiquer une femme sur sa
politique on vous attaquera pour sexisme
mais je ne peux pas dire de mareth
margaret thatcher est une [ __ ] parce
qu'elle a serré la main à pinochet s'il
convient qu'il ya pas de politique
féminine ça ne veut rien dire elles sont
souvent méchante comme détails mais ça
dépend de quelle origine sociale elles
sont un bien sûr moi j'aime beaucoup
disent michele j'aime beaucoup rosa
luxembourg j'ai aucun respect pour
madame thatcher c'est pas parce que
c'est une femme c'est parce que
politiquement dans la défense des lions
ainsi c'est tout
n'est pas non plus j'adore rosa
luxembourg comme théoricien marxiste
j'adore louise michel qui sont souvent
des ouvrières à des intellectuels la
chaise du cese
un moment je veux la conversation puis
j'ai encore une grande amie la duchesse
d'uzès et
que je veux savoir que la duchesse
d'uzès qui est une petite rue
rochechouart fortement à financer louise
michel avant de même que la reine
elizabeth avait tout fait pour virer
margaret thatcher parce qu'elle la
trouvait arrogante nuls ah ouais quand
même donc voilà vous êtes assez proche
marrade royaume a eu beaucoup
d'aristocrates dans le camp du
progressisme quand la bourgeoisie les a
virés pour faire pire que oui ça se
comprend ça c'est vrai voilà bien alors
donc les chiennes de garde la semaine de
garde donc ça a commencé avec dominique
voynet qui s'est fait insulter en
septembre 99 les chiennes de garde aura
donc exigé parce que laure adler avait
été victime d'insultés racistes on peut
le dire de la part de fo oui du syndicat
fo de syndicats y voient la rue et puis
après il ya martine aubry qui s'est fait
insulter par un patron s'est dit qu'est
ce qu'il avait dit le patron au sujet de
martine aubry oui elle avait dû dire
qu'elle était mal baisées et sans doute
ou quelque chose comme ça oui vous ce
qu'il fallait c'est un parachutiste je
cours à
116 8 la plus blessante
un homme d'une femme
j'aimerais comprendre chez roselyne
c'est que l'inric vous défendez vous
défendez celles qui sont qui sont mises
heures en cause comme ça insulter parce
qu'elles sont femmes simplement mais la
mémé siobhan ne se résume quand même pas
ça non mais c'est vrai mais en même
temps on est tous insulter c'est à dire
que lui et sur par exemple j'imagine
sale pauvre on a dû lui dire c'est
triste comme ça le macho je suis les a
lus et pourquoi je ferais pas un procès
pour la salle noire manon mois elodie
les
travailleurs employés portait pas
plainte au nom de la défense du
chasselas le chasseur personne n'empêche
de faire un collectif géré si la police
avait chargé en face qui vous ont marché
sur le pied effectivement s'il ya plus
de police et c'est le niveau zéro sa
position la politique à lyon c'est
la musique voilà ce qu'est ce que font
les gens sinon de se battre pour
défendre des intérêts légitimes ou
illégitimes c'est bien ça pour vous la
politique c'est chacun défend son petit
intérêt mais c'est comme ça c'est un peu
des moindres la princesse erika il s'est
alors moi je suis une femme je suis noir
je suis un vaste âge défend les femmes
noires astana d'or au départ mais c'est
un peu c'est l'argent mais ça peut
d'élargir à la l'humanité
moi je préfère je préfère me faire
traiter de gros contenants en tant que
de savoir qu'à un moment donné pour des
raisons de stricte profit il ya une
branche entière de l'économie française
qui va être liquidé des mecs vont être
poussées la misère et devenir des sdf
parce que la vraie violence allait quand
même là
bien sûr que ça s'appelle la politique
c'est bien d'avoir mis le doigt dessus
c'est ça la politique
vous êtes un macho quand on lit votre
bouquin sociologie du dragueur quand
vous parlez de vos piège à filles vous
draguez là dans la rue en bombant le
torse et ce livre là c'est pas très bon
donc c'est pas très sympa vous parler du
livre avant on parlait de celui de la
bruine vous êtes un écrivain sénégalais
c'est votre éditeur qui dit dans le
machin exact que ce livre reprend en
gros la deuxième partie du précédent
ouvrage sociologie du dragueur
attention alors pour moi un macho c'est
quoi c'est un homme qui respecte sa mère
qui protège sa femme qui se sent
responsable de ses enfants il ya
beaucoup de femmes aujourd'hui qu'ils
aimeraient rencontrer des machos celle
qui se trompe laquait avec deux gosses
logique libérale dans une logique
libérale tout ce qui est en voie de
disparition prendre la valeur il n'y a
pas plus valorisé sur le terrain
symbolique que le match aujourd'hui un
potentiel manuel a tenu parole en bouche
et au figaro
mardi pour
que vous cherchez un boulot
c'est bien et c'est bien qu'une dame du
rpr comme punition ne propose un poste
aux filières
avec la baisse de rose
quand on est de gauche et qu'on va
roselyne bachelot on a quand même c'est
le seul argument pour voter à droite
c'est ça la social démocratie c'est
qu'il ya une différence entre la gauche
et la droite ça devient de l'animation
culturelle est pénalisé pour les gens
qui sait du look quoi c'est à dire qu'il
ya un peu les gens qui préféreront
balzac à marguerite duras alors ils vont
voter on voit bien aujourd'hui que le
problème c'est qu'à plus de sion ne
vient pas de rapporter plus de 2 de
connivence entre le parti socialiste et
l'udf qui seront des gens du tertiaire
et les professions libérales et que
prennent du rpr que ses anciens patrons
de pme pmi qui sont en train d'être
liquidé aujourd'hui perdre leurs bases
historiques et que donc on verra si les
udf et rpr son coup d'arrêt inattendu
est-ce qu'on peut le musée est un petit
peu d'humour unir ses chaînes
thématiques qui nous réussit
vous êtes mosaïque et pour être sûr de
ne rien rater de nos latitudes abonnez
vous y mettez un peu de bleu